hey guys pete here have to say up front
this video is going to contain some book
spoilers about what happened at the end
of season 5 of the expanse
and about the breakaway martian fleet
and their plan for laconia
the opening excerpt i'm going to read is
from the epilogue of the fifth book
so now you have been warned the screen
flipped to a series of technical
drawings
there was more than enough about those
to disturb him as well
they called all the alien technology by
the name protomolecule but of course
that far traveled set of life-hijacking
microparticles was only one object in a
much grander toolbox
and if cortizaar had interpreted the top
clearance data from the mcrn probes
correctly
what they had found would be much easier
for humanity to tame and make use of
still the changes cortazar wanted for
the bar keith were unpleasantly organic
less like they were fitting a new model
of airlock on the ship
and more like they were carving it into
some kind of colossal prosthesis
it's the beginning of something very new
and very powerful
and if good people don't step in to
accept the power
bad ones will it was what admiral duarte
had told him the night he'd brought
soviter into the fold it had been true
then
and it was true now he switched on the
camera adjusted his hair
and began recording alright so a lot of
people were asking for information about
what happened to the bar keith what's
going on beyond the laconia ring
and what exactly we were looking at in
that end credit scene
i'm gonna look at some of the things we
know from the books but in a way i hope
encourages you to go out and read them
yourself rather than me just giving
things away that are confirmed in the
final trilogy
the show obviously cuts a lot of things
that happen in the books out
and one place where this really jumped
out at me watching season 5 for the
first time was in monica's story
when she first meets with holden on
tycho she brings him
information about ships going missing as
they're transiting the ring
out of 470 ships passing through the
rings
13 of those had just vanished it's a
relatively small number
but if you think about it in percentages
it's almost
a three percent loss rate because holden
has a healthy fear of
all things gate builder related after
his experiences with the investigator
inside the ring station
and on illus the missing ships obviously
pique his interest
and he starts to look into it monica had
a plan when she came to him
and that was to use fred johnson's
protomolecule sample
to try to contact the investigator
directly
but he's not interested in trying that
at all he starts to dig around
but then there's plenty to distract him
from the missing ships when the rocks
hit earth and then that goes on the back
burner for the most part
at the same time bobby's running an
investigation on mars
she meets up with alex after he comes
back and she asked him to use his
contacts at the navy
to try to talk to somebody about some
missing ships she's come across
in the show this is where he goes to
hear soviter speak at the war college
and later has dinner with babbage in the
books he meets with someone different
he meets with a commander named winston
duarte
off the record duarte says he's been
noticing things going missing as well
he's doing his own investigation
but since he's in on it he tries to
point alex in the wrong direction
he gives alex the name of someone to go
talk to but when he gets there he finds
out this person has been murdered
so by the time the bar keith approaches
the laconia gate the idea that some
ships go into the rings but never come
out the other side is already
established the bar keith is our example
of what that looks like when it happens
from what we see in the show and the
description of the event in the book
it's clear that we're supposed to
connect this to the unknown aggressors
the alien entities that killed off the
gate builder civilization
i already went into that in my season 5
ending explain video so i won't do it
again
but at this point in the story there
really aren't any other suspects that
could be behind these ships
disappearances
based on the small set of data almost
three out of every hundred ships that
transit the rings disappear
holden never really figured anything out
but at the end of book five when naomi
comes back and they're reunited
she takes an interest in this data as
well things are such a mess that nobody
really is paying attention to this
colony ships are disappearing and those
are loaded up with a lot of things that
are useful
especially to belters so some people are
chalking it up to piracy
outside of monica naomi and holden and
the rest of the rossi crew
it's just not on the top of anybody's
list to look into
and because the bar keith is part of the
breakaway fleet and the free navy is now
controlling medina station
that disappearance isn't something
people are going to be paying attention
to
outside of the lakonians themselves so
who are these people
duarte is mentioned in the excerpt i
opened the video with although you'll
notice he's promoted himself to the rank
of admiral but it's the same guy that
alex met
and he is the brains behind the
operation the show switched out
alex meeting with soviter instead of
duarte
but duarte is still named whenever
sobiter's talking to marco
notice that soviter says he was brought
into the fold
and the simple declaration from duarte
really sums things up he says
it's the beginning of something very new
and very powerful and if good people
don't step in to accept the power
bad ones will so obviously in this
scenario duarte sees himself
and this breakaway fleet that he put
together as the good people
and their motivation to break away to
make a move
is everything we saw happen in the first
four seasons
first we had the proto-molecule it
arrived on an extrasolar object
it's created by an alien civilization
while it's incredibly dangerous and
turns out to cause a lot of problems
there's really not a scenario where
humanity doesn't do something with it
same thing with the ring gates opening
there's plenty of reasons not to use
them
but it's not realistic to think that
people won't if you think about real
world history
there really isn't any example you can
think of where an
opportunity for advancement like this
presented itself
and humanity said no i don't think
that's a good idea and just walked away
from it that's really at the core
of what duarte believes and he also
thinks that the current leaders of mars
and the martian military as it is are
making critical mistakes
and they're letting the opportunity pass
them by they think that the
opportunity to colonize the new planets
that all have breathable atmospheres
will be the end of the martian dream on
mars so they want to take that
somewhere else they want to start with a
clean slate and make it pure
and they want to be free to apply it
without anything holding them back
in the show we got that from soviter and
babbage's conversation
and you see that she has the kool-aid
drinker look in her eyes
when she says we need to be more pure
than mars
ever was that's who they are
as far as how they picked the laconia
system that's hinted at
in the excerpt as well it says if
cortazar had
interpreted the top clearance data from
the mcrn probes correctly what they had
found
would be much easier for humanity to
tame and make use of
when the ring gates opened mars and
earth rushed to send probes through the
gates to see what was on the other side
they collected a lot of data and had a
pretty good idea about what the systems
looked like
due to his position duarte had access to
this data and he noticed that the planet
laconia
had a protomolecule artifact orbiting it
that's what we see in the sky behind
cortazar in the tv show and i'll get
into a little bit more about what that
is
towards the end of the video duarte's
plan was to get a hold of some active
proto-molecule
find the best scientists he could to
work with it and create enough chaos
inside soul
system that he could get to laconia and
set up shop
they know what happened on ellis but
think the rewards outweigh the risks of
turning things on and decide to take the
gamble
cortazar is an important part of this
equation because he is quite literally
the person with the most experience
studying the proto-molecule
he's also had his brain altered while he
was at protogen
to relieve him of any pesky hang-ups
that might come along from having
empathy
so he has that going on as well the show
sort of switched up how he came to be
employed by duarte
there's actually a whole novella called
the vital abyss that covers his
unorthodox recruitment for the project
that's definitely worth a read if you
want an idea of how duarte decides that
he's the right guy
so that's who the breakaway fleet are
and how they chose laconia as their new
home
as far as the ships going dutchman or
being eaten when they try to transit the
rings
we should learn a lot more about that in
the next season
the novella strange dogs covers the
period of time when the proto-molecule
arrives on laconia
from the perspective of a family of some
of the first scientists that were there
and i highly recommend reading that we
might even see some of that
in season six because the timelines sort
of overlap
now i'll explain what the end credit
scene is but i'll give you another
chance to bow out
first because it does spoil some future
plot point
you still really should read the books
yourself to experience these things as
they were intended but since the
information is out there on the wiki i
will talk about it here
it's not like i'm in possession of some
esoteric scrolls or something
and i've seen it out there where people
say that they guessed what it was just
from watching the show
anyway what you see in the sky orbiting
laconia
is a pair of orbiting platforms that the
gate builders used for building their
ship
what duarte saw was that they had left a
ship or something like it halfway
through its construction
he saw this as an opportunity to get
that technology for himself
get the sample and the right scientists
and pick up the gate builders work
right where they left off as the credits
roll and we move through the clouds we
see that he's put the plan into action
as there's a glimpse of the active
proto-molecule on the gate builders
unfinished ship
and that is where i'll leave things go
read the books i've got links to them in
the description
let me know what you think about this
video what you think about what's going
on with the laconians
and if you want to talk about future
spoilers that's cool
just mark them if they go into future
plot points please like this video if
you enjoyed it please subscribe
to my channel if you haven't already
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon